- I am a very good test taker.
- I'm a terrible test taker.
- I think I'm a pretty
fantastic test taker.
- Why do they have a
separate literacy test?
I don't understand.
Is it a racist thing?
Ah, go.
- This test is to be given to anyone
who cannot prove a fifth grade education.
- One wrong answer denotes
failure of the test.
- You have ten minutes
to complete this test.
- Why are there two firsts?
- Yeah, that's where I'm like,
- What?
What?
- Wow does my head hurt.
- But that doesn't, what does,
that doesn't make sense to me.
- This is a literacy quiz?
- Ah, it's the Illuminati eye.
- Spell backwards forwards.
(laughter)
- I gotta move faster.
- 30 questions?
Oh god.
- I'm killin' this game.
- Fuck.
- It's making me feel very
competitive right now.
Like, we have to.
- I'm, I'm dead.
I'm just giving up.
Okay, okay, okay.
- This is hard.
- We got to question 25.
- I would not be able to vote.
- I wouldn't either.
- Failed hardcore, because I
didn't even complete the test.
- I know that this test was intentionally
trying to trick me and it succeeded.
And that makes me really, really sad.
- The efforts to go to to make
discrimination officially,
it blows my mind.
- To be a black person and
to have the right to vote,
you had to literally get
through fucking riddles.
- It made me realize that
I take voting for granted.
- It makes me appreciate it more,
to be able to actually
have the right to vote.
Your duty, almost, as an American citizen
to vote.
- This is eye opening to
me in a different light,
because in Puerto Rico right now
we're a country of United States citizens,
and because we're a
territory we can't vote.
- I just think that we've found new ways
to suppress voting
rights in certain states
where there's only three or four places
where you can register to vote,
and they're miles and
miles away from counties
that have a predominantly
poor demographic.
- What makes me more upset is just knowing
that there's no like concrete answers.
The person who is administering the test
is the one who determines if it's right.
Yeah, this just proves that black people
should never say they
wanna go back in time.
There's just nothing better back there.